oish tape the tape pass here come the jackets
good R nice move who's in referee's calling it
a goal wow he's the first to acknowledge it
and the jackets have the lead Johnny good Ro
Johnny beautiful move and it goes right
off the pipe it looks like there on that
angle Jeff you can see he's trying to go glove
does touch a tiny piece of the glove and hits
maybe both posts there hit the crossfire and
the post yeah and came out that's how close
I mean you talk about goal scores and from
the Blue Jackets in good row After official
review it's determined that the puck did
not go into the net we have no goal on the
ice likely see a little of Kent Johnson I would
think as we approach the Midway Point
boquist deals marchenko turns and scor
Krill marchenko on the power play It's one nothing
Columbus penalty Blue Jacket make him pay
beautiful pass here but how marchenko changes
that angle and as he does see how doubt
he's in that shot Lane taking away they
try to take away that far side of the net
maybe a little too deep but baronov there
pulled bouty a little bit in and then marchenko
had so much time space down below look he's got
a cut on his eye there too Blue Jackets with
that power play goal now 29 first period goals
and they've scored the first goal in seven
of the last eight games idea here add to
it a 4 nothing win at Los Angeles here's an odd
man Rush it's a two-on one jackets move in copy
the save rebound swept wide yeah good job on the
two on one nice try but defense here's a drive
cople the save rebound scores baronov was right
there in front after the initial stop by Copley
kicks at it with the outside of Escape right there
shoves it pass Copley after review was determined
that the puck was kicked into the net therefore
we have no goal now there you have it quick
decision here's kimp mov by rinsky
and walked out by kopar Andre kopar
spent stepped up could not paral
the puck and here's gdo G streaks
in fire scores oh you can't deny me a
second chance and G buries it it's two
nothing after he loses his stick now he
gets his stick back he's at the bottom
of your left of your screen the defenseman
had jumped up on the play and Johnny good
was back there and that puck bounces towards
him and this time Copley doesn't get any of
it and Johnny goodro puts it right inside
the pipe perfect shot by him he's got his
fourth tempted to knock the puck down could not
Bish with an attempted shot here's rinsky Zack
moves in off the goal post lots of movement
at the top of the zone and here comes texi AC
not focused on the puck he interferes with that
lane and and as he does he he just try to slow
down theair air a little bit of the night well
when you're a healthy scratch like that for so
long it's all you think about corally fites off
tried to poke it home and Copley sees one of his
teammates a momentum that was a beautiful play by
Tex now he keeps that puck good focus by him too
and that momentum keeps that puck with him Jack
it's course it turnover it's a two onone moving in
dead for there's the pass the broke head pull the
trigger still with it though fires down is Copley
he's got it jacket try to jam it free it does not
look out of place does he no he doesn't he knows
his role and he just the effort and tenacity
and you know he likes the physical games shot
blocked jaet get it back scores the all important
third goal oh yeah Olivier you think he's happy
wow it's a good spot for him in the Tex have
switched and he's a guy that's down there just
creating havoc and as that puck gets broken
up he jumps all over it beautiful play here
as that shot comes in from the point he
finds the broken play and yes celebrate
hustles in he's got ke heading to the net now
a clearing pass marchenko moving in fires save
cley the jackets will want to protect what
is a three goal lead just underway Bo along
the wall right Point Long Shot scores
may have been deflected in front but
the Kings 23 seconds in are on the board
and as his play is made High Den know is
going to come out in front of the net and
his stick is reaching out right there he's
coming actually towards the puck and as he is
he gets that stick on it nothing Elvis murans
can do there you can see Pak is trying
to get in the way of that Puck and as he
is comes to the right Point Dy Anderson oh that
one was redirected off the back wall oh what
a sensational save reaching out with the glove
as Elvis ver leans and that's his fight a save
as you will see cuz he knows he's got this on his
back hand it's a Rolling Puck Elvis is out locked
on the other side you can see doesn't get a lot of
it but he gets enough to try to hit that over for
more from the LA Kings but it went wide Kings keep
it in moving tempted shot blocked now a cross ice
pass here's a shot Elvis looks behind him where
is it it's on the line and in that's Matthew Den
know again Puck was but the referee found it and
did not blow his whistle there it is it's just
sitting there and you can see Deno he can see it
and then he gets the tip of his stick k on it the
Blue Jackets players are boxed to the outside
here no whistle no Whistle Too Much Time there
for matu do know to stand there throws it behind
the net dowy up high a wrist shot F off the goal
stick tipped in front with Dan for Dan for takes
the pass Dan for tried to return it goes between
the legs of the defender Ru that puck rolled on
Danforth just as he tried to make a move here's
cab looking to come in on the right right wing
calev in front Elis looks behind him and they
tied it the Los Angeles Kings have come from
a three-goal deficit and we are tied at three
and a Blue Jackets just try to swap pucks out
of their own end and this last play Provo was
up in the play now he's back and you can see a
little Collision off that back post it's him and
boquist right there and then Elvis is spun around
trying to figure out where that puck is if he
thought it went in right away or what but he was
looking for it and then it just gets swept behind
him naov was asking for it waving he's got
two assists here in the third period here
Trevor Mo and that's bought off by m lein cross
ice rensy he'll send it ahead danf for tries to
get a stick on it puck in deep Anderson takes
a hit left Point rinsky knocked down by Dan for
Jack it's heaven in the slot oh my right there
was good R Copley got a piece of it ke straddles
the Blue Line kopar carries in kopar drops it
there for kempe kempe in turn dowy Kopitar dowy
with a shot and scores the Kings come from
a three-goal deficit and Win It seconds into
overtime four unanswered goals he just put it
in the perfect spot nice exchange and he just
unloads that puck I mean that was so close it was
perfect he just unloaded that puck right off the
inside of that post little exchange on the give
what go they isolate you see marchenko just loses
DY for that much time and as he does dowy puts
it as tight as you can put it inside the post